Oh what is going on you too now if
you've ever been a boyfriend you know
that there is one thing that
consistently scares the [ __ ] out of you
and this fear comes once every month and
no it's not because of your fear of
commitment it's not because your
girlfriend's gonna leave you or cheat on
you it's your girlfriend's don't you
[ __ ] say it period that menstruation
cycle the week of [ __ ] doom now
boyfriend's of the earth do not fret
because I am here to help cause you see
my friends I have [ __ ] up so much I
know exactly what to do and especially
what not to do so I am here to help you
survive your girlfriend's period tip
number one as you notice in the previous
clip clearly I [ __ ] up I will count
your [ __ ] eyes out listen you know
what your words are harsh but imma let
that go because you are on don't you
[ __ ] say it here you never blame your
girlfriend bad mood on her period yes in
your mind even though you know it's true
you do not tell your girlfriend she has
an [ __ ] because of it she will snap
your dick off like a celery stalk and
you might be thinking to yourself but it
true and I'm right know during her
period you are always wrong tip number
two the jokes that you normally say to
her are no longer funny you are not
funny but I say these jokes to her all
the time no no no no you are not
yeah you are so clumsy hey you are so
clumsy why would you say what still tip
number three because of all the stupid
[ __ ] that you said earlier be prepared
to be told why you ain't [ __ ] whatever
no about a woman's pain huh I don't know
anything about a woman's pain but you
know but here's me you're being me and
for the love of God do not tell her she
being mean I'm being mean I'm the one
being mean because my uterus that's a
break open it have a [ __ ] baby what
do you have to do you go just and then
you just chill on some woman and then
you're done your job is done
what do you have to do you take a [ __ ]
and jizz
yeah tip number four be prepared for the
read the mood swing yes to us she will
seem bipolar and she was like your hair
so cute yeah oh
are you listening to me what Felicity
it's not that she's bipolar it's just
she got all this hormonal and biological
[ __ ] that's going down that's toying
with her emotions men had that too is
just that we don't have it on a time
schedule basically back the [ __ ] off and
finally tip number five be ready for the
different types of mood swings if you
think for one goddamn second that every
time her period comes around every month
and she's gonna have the exact same mood
as the last time you stupid as [ __ ] cuz
you might get the angry one you might
get the irrational emotional one yes
what do you want to watch movie tonight
um yeah sure which one uh I was thinking
that one Johnny Depp movie Black Mass
yeah like nuts yes what's going on it's
not what the movies about or my personal
favorite that narcoleptic so I was
thinking for dinner we could have Lucy
this is [ __ ] sleeping with her eyes
open
all in all my friends just be prepared
to weather the storm and know that she
is not doing this on purpose it's just
some biological [ __ ] that's going on she
can't help it you've had bad days too so
back the [ __ ] off oh and by the way
another fucked-up thing about a period
for you guys that don't know your girl
will get more frisky while she's on her
period yeah that's [ __ ] up oh this is
so weird I have white sheets you know do
you have a thick pad because I have one
no don't do it get your [ __ ] off my
[ __ ] sheet you know what tampons and
penises both can go in same time you
know hey what's going on YouTube I hope
you guys liked that video featuring
Julie's on it's been a while since we've
been in a video together but that crazy
[ __ ] is back in here but yes man I used
to be just like you I used to fear the
[ __ ]
period like it was the Chupacabra that
will come to steal your goats every
month but yes everybody videos every
Wednesday and Sunday on my youtube or
you can go ahead and check me out on
vessel if you want to go ahead and cop
the views a little earlier and [ __ ] like
that
so I will see you guys Wednesday and
Sunday subscribe subscribe and like this
video for me because I don't know if you
love me give it a go follow me on
Instagram and Facebook and all the other
[ __ ]